in the New York Times says a Facebook
report shows the social network deleted
865 million posts in the first quarter
of this year most of them were spam
Facebook also removed two and a half
million pieces of hate speech in the
first quarter just over a third of it
was detected by Facebook's artificial
intelligence technology the rest was
flagged by users Facebook says this
shows that the artificial intelligence
programs it wants to monitor the social
network are still years away from being
effective the revelation comes amid what
Salesforce CEO Marc Benioff calls a
crisis of trust in the tech industry
Benioff is the founder and CEO and
chairman of cloud computing company
Salesforce Salesforce builds software
that connects business with its
customers it has 30,000 employees and
more than 150,000 customers worldwide
mark good morning good morning thank you
for having me again thank you for
weighing in on our rural test here I
definitely heard Yanni yeah I just want
to know what it means right young ears
mr. Binney off we all want to know a
crisis of trust well you can see that
our industry is going through a very
significant crisis of trust we have seen
it over the last year just with an uber
with Facebook actually other companies
and in some ways you could say Facebook
has really become the new cigarettes in
our industry that is it's a technology
that is yeah it's addictive it may not
be that great for you and it might be
something that you might want to go back
to so maybe this is a time where the
government has to step in and regulate
not just that product but really our
industry or really at that point with
technology even Facebook has said it now
when you people talk about regulations
but what do you really mean I mean do
you want to ban ads that use personal
information give us some specifics here
about what regulation would really mean
we really need at this country a
national privacy law you can see it's
going into effect in Europe it's called
gdpr and that means that in Europe your
data belongs to you but in the United
States your data belongs to all these
companies that are collecting it and
they can do with it basically whatever
they want and that's a shift that we
have to make you can see that's about to
happen in California where I'm from
there is a
the statewide privacy law on that it's
moving its way to voters but what we
need is a national privacy law and that
will really not just protect the tech
industry it's gonna protect all the
consumers ultimately it's gonna protect
our kids which is really what this is
all about because look we we know that
all these companies are now looking to
bring kids into their into their social
networks as well isn't their business
model built though on selling some of
our personal data or marketing it it's
so rare to default upon or for somebody
in your position to be calling for
regulation yeah look I'm trying to
protect our industry I see the huge
advancements that are happening every
day in our industry it's amazing I mean
you could see what just happened last
week with Google duplex that was the
most amazing AI technology I've seen
it's indistinguishable from human being
when you're talking to it many people in
the computer industry feel that it
passed the Turing test that means wow is
that a human or is that a computer so if
we're at that point we need to start to
have better regulation and greater
controls the Europeans understand that
it's time for the Americans to
understand that too can I just go back
to the National privacy law what would
that do for me how would that work in
practice for me with my personal
information that would mean that
companies would have to fully disclose
how they collect your information use
your information and you'd have a right
to be forgotten so that if you want all
your information deleted you can hit
that button and be assured that your
data is gone forever you are known as an
activist CEO you know you certainly have
critics and supporters and one of the
one of the issues you've taken on is
gender equality which you are loved by
women in this country for that because
you've taken this by both hands and say
look you can't be a CEO really and not
take on gender equality well you're
absolutely right and you know that
everywhere I go I try to bring you know
25 CEOs together at a time we're at a
dinner table like I did last night with
you and say to them look we all have to
focus on critical issues that are so
important right now and one of them is
gender equality and gender equality is
number one equal advancement equal
opportunity but you know gender equality
also means equal pay which means that
men and women need to be paid the same
for the same work and see
those need to be held accountable for
making sure that they are equally paying
men and women and also it's about
preventing sexual harassment you can't
have gender equality without knowing
that you've got psychological safety in
your work in your workplace and that you
can you know work together within your
own company though you walk in you see a
meeting full of white guys and you just
said hey what's wrong with this picture
that you're even working to change that
at your own company well that's exactly
right I mean I see that every single day
we're and that's how I got involved I
said how are we going to change how do
we gonna improve our work with for
example women and that's why we've
improved the number of women that we
have in our company but also why we've
now spent more than nine million dollars
to balance out our pay scales to make
sure that we are paying men and women
equally you know that's something that
every CEO can do with one button you
know we don't we don't run our business
on three by five cards right you know
that Gail yeah we use computers that
means we can say oh we know exactly how
everyone is being paid you did that
internal audit essentially and we're
surprised by what you found even in your
own company what have other CEOs said to
you perhaps privately about why they
haven't done what you've done well the
vast majority of CEOs are afraid to push
that button because you don't really
know what's gonna come out of the system
and it's a big leap of faith but it's a
leap of faith we all have to make
because look we're all trying to improve
our workplaces you know Salesforce was
just awarded the number one best place
to work by Fortune magazine in the world
yeah very proud of that
and you know the reason why we were able
to get there is look it's gender
equality is extremely important all
aspects of a quality important diversity
inclusion is it's critical LGBTQ
equality is critical you know the last
time we were here I was talking about
you know what we were doing in Indiana
and in Georgia and you know that even
the environment is equality we talked
about that last night where we've got to
be thinking and CEOs have to take
responsibility for their products when
it comes to it I'll bet environment
Joe's it's a-okay mr. Binney I'll stop
talking we got a business to run here
but I think it's good you're speaking up
thank you very much yeah thank you for
coming always a pleasure to
thank you thank you